he's albert brier senior nfl reporter
and also
a contributor to monday morning
quarterback he joins us on the program
why is le'veon bell great fit for kansas
city well you mentioned the short
yardage thing i think that's certainly a
factor
dan that damian williams who had served
in that role for the chiefs opted out
so that left a hole in the roster i
think the other thing is they still love
clyde edwards lair
um part of the thing with him though you
look at his
history he really only was a bell cow
for one year at lsu
like all rookies he's never played a
season as long as he's going to play
this year and they've been relying on
him pretty heavily over the first month
of the season so
this allows them to move clyde edwards
hillary to maybe a little bit more of a
situational role
now which potentially could mean you get
more out of him in december
in january and february the other thing
that i'd mentioned quietly
their offensive line's been a little bit
of an issue and if you look back when
they struggled against the 49ers early
in the super bowl when they struggled
early against the chargers
in week two when they struggled against
the patriots and then when they lost
last week
in all those games you see at the line
of scrimmage they're having some issues
and so one way to mitigate some of those
issues is to add a great running back
who
can you know churn out tough yards can
help you in pass protection and le'veon
bell brings all of those things so
the hope is you get a motivated player
here helps you preserve clyde
clyde edwards lair a little bit and
maybe helps you mitigate what's been a
little bit of an issue on the offensive
line
why is there a mystery around the
indianapolis colts in their game this
weekend
i don't think it's much of a mystery dan
i mean i think this is all sort of a
result of what happened with the titans
and the patriots over the last few weeks
and this is sort of where we're
where we are and i think where we're
going to be for the rest of the season
where
when any team has multiple uh positive
tests over the course of a few days
they're going to shut down the facility
in the short term
um you know i don't think it would have
happened three or four weeks ago
this way um but you know based on what
happened on tennessee i think this is
sort of the way that everybody is going
to move forward now
it's sort of interesting too you know
you look at it and
you know a lot of people have and
rightfully have said like these teams
should be acting with the most caution
they possibly can and not trying to pull
through this
well now that they are you're hit you
you it's hard for like me to turn around
and say okay like now we'll hit the
panic button like this is what you asked
for you wanted them to be more cautious
i think they should be more cautious
now they are being cautious and every
time one of these comes up
people want to hit the panic button i
just think they're acting out of caution
um and in all likelihood it'll it'll be
a situation like the falcons had earlier
this week where
they had two positive tests they shut
down for a day and they're back in the
building this morning
what's odell beckham jr's mysterious
illness
i think it's a normal illness and you
know that's another thing dan that we're
gonna be dealing with you know i
you know because the testing isn't
perfect and and i think there have been
cases not just in football but
nationwide
you know where people come down with it
and then they consistently test negative
um this is gonna be tricky for the nfl
because every time somebody comes
up with this comes down the stomach bug
with the flu
with a cold you almost have to treat it
like it's covet even if the guy is
testing negative
um and you know you've been around the
league for a long time dan i mean
the stuff that guys fight through in
november and december on an annual basis
the things that teams do to manage the
flu in their locker room so guys can
play
um you know it's like the amount of guys
that that are doing that
every single year the public doesn't
know this but it's huge you know and so
this could add a very real and different
dynamic to the rest of the season where
you know guys just come down with normal
sicknesses that you would get any
november or december and now you got to
shelve them for a week or two because
you're worried that it could be coveted
even if the guy is testing negative
stuff on gilmore cam newton good to go
yeah there you go
and um you know that's that's another
interesting one because they
uh you know obviously i think it's a
story because those are two very huge
names and
the patriots had a total of four tests
over that period but
uh yeah i mean i think we saw the system
at work you know over the last few days
where um i i don't think cam would have
played against the broncos
um had the game been held last weekend
and now you know that game gets delayed
and we have sort of this inequity now
the other side of it the interesting
part about it is
you know it also brought bought the
broncos time to get drew lock healthy
and he had a shoulder injury and so
you know where you know six days ago we
would have had
i think ripon versus hoyer or ripon
versus stidum
now we're getting newton versus lock
which is another kind of interesting
quirk to the way all this works
you look at some teams obviously we have
top heavy there's some really good teams
but we have a
a whole lot there's an abundance of bad
teams right now
and we know that that that prize at the
end of the season could be trevor
lawrence here
at what point does a team say it is
smarter for us like the jets
or i mean you know the giants uh maybe
to a lesser degree but
at what point do you think these teams
start to strategize of
this is what's best for us bigger
picture long-term
particularly if you're the jets right
now yeah i think our point of reference
dan is probably
2011 um you know because i i mean i
i mean look like i've talked to scouts
over the last two years about trevor
lawrence
um and you know the consensus i'd say
across the board is this is a once in a
decade type of
prospect you know and if you want to
look over the last 40 years
john elway peyton manning andrew luck
trevor lawrence like i think that that's
he's that good a prospect and so if you
remember at the end of um of the 2011
season there were some questions about
how the colts were managing their roster
and there was all kinds of buzz how
other teams were gonna handle it the
rams were one of those you might
remember
and so um i don't think it happens yet
but i think once we get to around
thanksgiving
it starts to crystallize what teams are
actually in the running for that last
for that first overall pick
maybe we start to see some stuff as of
right now you know the
the thing that prevents it from
happening now is most bad teams have
people in positions of power that are
fighting for their jobs
so their mentality is i need to save my
job i'm not worried about what's
happening in 2021
but as we get later in the year i
certainly think that that could become a
factor well you got the trade deadline
coming up in a couple of weeks can you
see the jets trade sam darnold and would
there be a taker could the falcons trade
matt ryan would there be a taker would
the lions trade matthew stafford would
there be a taker
i don't think so my guess is you
wouldn't see one of the quarterbacks
traded
let's start with the jets and darnold i
you know you'd be
gambling big time that you wind up with
the number one overall pick
um and i think that the jets trading
donald would have to be tied to having
the number one overall pick
so my guess is like sam darnold probably
winds up
on the roster the rest of the year and
whatever they do with sam darnold
depends on
kind of rises on where they're picking
in april and so
you know i i think sam darnold would
have a ton of value out there
um i i think baseline what josh rosen
um brought home for the cardinals a
couple years ago which was a two and a
five
um but i do think it could wind up being
as much as a late one like say your
pittsburgh for example
an executive brought this up to me the
other day do you flip the 25th pick in
the draft for sam darnold now you have
your potential replacement for ben
roethlisberger
to me that makes a lot of sense because
the steelers may never be picking high
enough to
get a trevor lawrence or a trade lancer
at justin field so
i think sam darnold will have some value
you know with matt ryan i think the
falcons would need to be blown away i
know arthur blank and rich mckay would
like to leave that up
to whoever the next coach and gm are um
and then in detroit i think this is
you know again sort of a situation where
everybody there is fighting for their
job
so unless the plug gets pulled on bob
quinn or matt patricia i i think they're
counting on matt stafford to help them
turn it around and convince the ford
family to keep them in 2021.
a couple of things i was told prior to
the draft um
that the colts were really interested in
jordan love and then the packers went up
and got him
because they knew that that was going to
be the air apparent to philip rivers
and then with the lions that they were
really kicking the tires on tua
and i don't know if you heard that but
that was from you know a a source of
mine
uh who i trust but like that explains a
little bit about
green bay worried that maybe
indianapolis was going to swoop in and
take him and then
would tua go to detroit and i was told
that that staff in detroit was saying
look if we don't make this work this
year we're not going to have these jobs
and therefore they didn't want to go in
on tua and then maybe try to do
something with staffers that sound right
yeah and i i can tell you dan i can add
to that um you know detroit's really
kicked the tires on quarterbacks for the
last two years
in fact if you guys remember um dave
gettleman
saying there were two teams he was
worried about um when he drafted daniel
jones sixth instead of 17th overall
one of those teams i think it was out
there was washington jay gruden really
liked daniel jones
i was told the other team was detroit
the the giants had information that
detroit was really interested in daniel
jones as well and so it's not that they
don't like stafford i think they really
they love matthew stafford personally
and as a player the injuries have sort
of piled up and so
that's caused them to at least take a
hard look at quarterbacks not just last
year but over the last two years
um and what was the other one you
mentioned there i mentioned uh jordan
love to the court jordan love
the co i think the colts so the way the
colts view
few phillip rivers right now he's buying
them time chris ballard was
in in kansas city with uh with john
dorsey right
um and andy reid and they had alex smith
on the roster and what alex smith
allowed them to do was but
it bought them time to find the
long-term answer and then when they saw
somebody they really liked they got very
aggressive and went up and got them
and so the colts are in that sort of
they've sort of created that window for
themselves where
all right like we got philip rivers for
right now hopefully this buys us a
little time to find the right guy
i would not be surprised at all dan if
the colts are ultra aggressive and
trying to move up to go and get one of
the top three
probably won't be lawrence but maybe a
fields or a lance when we get to when we
get to april
yeah and i still go back to you know i
was told that the saints were going to
take
patrick mahomes if he was there like
isn't that amazing
how yep that was who so so so i you know
they were picking 11th that year
that was who brett veach like brett
veach had strong information
that the saints um the saints really
really loved him and were planning to
take him 11. so that was sort of the
pressure point
that the chiefs had to leap over the
saints and they wound up with the 10th
pick
um that was where they needed to go to
get mahomes and i could tell you
there are two quarterbacks that sean
payton has stood on the table for
um in new orleans over the last five
years or so
one was patrick mahomes the other one he
really loved was baker mayfield
but you know patrick mahomes would be
third string because he'd be behind
taysom hill on the depth chart in new
orleans though
right and maybe fighting with james for
a roster spot right
are you a taste some uh taysom hillis
base of my eyes um no
based on my eye but my eyes are telling
me is there's not
um they're they're we just haven't seen
enough like i just haven't seen enough
he's 30 years of age albert it's not
like you know this is and i know and
that's the thing that's the thing i keep
coming back to is like shouldn't we be
seeing
more now but then based on my years and
you hear the way people in new orleans
talk about them and yeah i mean i
you know it's it's one of those things
where it's like you watch him and it's
like god they're like i don't
know like any time like they they
they're in a position where he has to
throw the ball
it's a complete crap shoot right but
then you look at the guy who's calling
the shots here and it's sean payton
who knows more about quarterbacks than
sean payton who's been better
at coaching and developing quarterbacks
over the last you know 15 years in the
nfl and sean payton and so
i i'd always you know defer to what sean
payton thinks and
it's not just what i'm hearing they gave
him a lot of money
you know and so like i i just like i
look at it and it's like
no i'm not seeing it like i'm with
everybody else on that but
shouldn't we trust sean payton on this i
feel like he's earned the benefit of the
doubt when it comes to that position
yeah no i feel like jameis winston is
more the future at that position
than uh taysom hill it could be could
and hey look like you know
i thought it was a great move by jamis
to go there like honestly to go
rehabilitate your your reputation go to
a place where you're going to get to
learn
both those guys taste them hill and
somebody down there mentioned this to me
you know a couple weeks ago um how you
know taysom and jamis
like imagine the graduate level
quarterbacking school that those guys
are in getting to watch drew brees work
on a day-to-day
basis i mean that's phenomenal for both
those guys you know so
i think jameis you know if if there is
something there
um i think jameis went to the place
that's going to find it you know
sean payton you know getting to work
with drew brees like
you'd have to think like the the
different factors in play in new orleans
would smoke out whatever sort of player
jameis winston can be
um over the next you know over the
course of the 2020 season
always great to talk to you albert we
appreciate the time and uh
have a great weekend thank you awesome
thanks dan that's albert brier
senior nfl reporter and of course uh
contributor to the mqbr